let's say i have the vector field
cv
the vector at any given point it's equal
to minus or the magnitude in my x
direction is actually dependent on y
so where we are on the the y-coordinate
in the x-y plane
plus and the magnitude in the
y-direction is dependent on x
fair enough
so first let's just
chug through this and figure out its
curl
so the curl of v
of v
it is equal to
our del
vector operator cross v
which is nothing but this
and even though this looks like a two
dimensional vector field
we actually have to take the cross
product in three dimensions because when
you curl is just like torque and when
you
like we did the right hand rule when we
studied well i hope you watch some of
the videos on magnetism and and torque
but the torque actually goes in a
direction that is perpendicular to both
of the vectors in your cross product so
your if if both of these only have x and
y components your actual result is going
to be in the z direction it's going to
be perpendicular to both of these
vectors so when you take the cross
product you still have to do it in three
dimensions
so i
j
k
partial with respect to x
partial with respect to y
partial with respect to z
the x component is minus y
the j component is x and we have no k
component
this one should be a little bit cleaner
to calculate than the last example
so this is going to be equal to we'll
see the i component let's cross it's out
its column and its row so it's going to
be the partial
with respect to y
of 0
minus the partial with respect to z
of x
right minus that and all of that times i
minus and that is going to be the j
component remember you do plus
minus plus
so minus as the j component cross out
its row and column the partial
derivative of x with respect to zero
or partial derivative of zero with
respect to x actually
minus the partial derivative
of
z
or the partial derivative with respect
to z of minus
y
that's its j component and then finally
plus it's k component row and column so
the partial derivative
of
the partial derivative with respect to x
of x
minus the partial derivative of
y with respect to
minus y i know you can't read it but
that's that minus y there and that's
this the k component
and now let's simplify it i'll simplify
it above it
so this term let's see partial
derivative of zero well that's zero
partial derivative of x with respect to
z well as far as z is concerned x is a
constant so that's zero
partial derivative of zero with respect
to x zero partial derivative of minus y
with respect to z
as far as z is concerned y is also
constant that's zero so all we're left
is with this last term that was pretty
straightforward now we just can cross
all of that out and that makes intuitive
sense too right because
at least for from x's point of view
the the rotation is although it's it's
the rotation if you think about is going
to be in a direction
it's going to be in a direction
perpendicular to both the x direction
and perpendicular to the direction in
which it is changing
you could kind of view it orthogonally
to its direction of motion which is y so
it would be in the z direction if that
confuses you don't worry about it but if
it doesn't then you know you can play
this you can apply the same argument to
the j vector but anyway let's simplify
this so this is equal to the partial
derivative of x with respect to x well
that's just one
minus the partial derivative of y of
minus y with respect to y well that's
just minus one
so it equals two
so the curl at any point of this vector
field is two
let's let's see what this vector field
looks like and let's see if that that
gives us uh if our if our intuition
holds in this example and let me try to
make it a little bit bigger
make the window bigger
there you go well i think it's clear for
you know right when you look at it that
this vector field looks like it's
spinning if you were to stick something
especially in the middle it's very clear
that it would spin but what might be a
little unintuitive you might think wow
wouldn't something spin faster near the
center than it would here why is the you
know the curl we got is two it's a
constant the curl is the same
throughout this entire vector field so
you'd be like well that that's kind of
implying that the field is making
something spin equally no matter where
you are in the field let's see if that
if that makes sense well in the middle
it definitely makes sense that something
is spinning right if i had a little
stick here i'd be pushing in this
direction with not that much of a
magnitude in that direction and then i'd
be pushing down to the right in this
direction so it would cause it to spin
but what if i had that same stick
here
right
you'd say well on the top right i'm
pushing up up
up into the left and the bottom left i'm
also pushing up into the left
you know it wouldn't spin as much but it
would because the difference in
magnitudes of these two you could almost
view them as you know the torque
producing forces the difference in
magnitude is enough that you still have
the same the same counterclockwise
rotation here as you would have here so
because the curl is a constant positive
number when we look at the xy plane like
this if you put a twig that same twig
anywhere where you put it on this plane
it will have the same counterclockwise
rotation i think that's pretty neat
now i wanna i wanna let's do a little
experiment what would have happened
what would have happened if
if this was plus y
so if let me let's just do that
experiment if this was plus y
if this was plus y then this would have
been plus y
then this then in this final term we
were taking the partial derivative with
respect to y of plus y
and so this would have been one minus
plus one and then our curl would have
been
zero which would have meant that we
would have had no rotation unless what's
the intuition of that well if we just
look at it mathematically if we have
zero curl somehow the rotation in our x
direction must be being offset by our
rotation in the y direction that the
torques must be just perfectly
offsetting each other let's see what
happens if i were to change so this was
our old graph let me actually change it
to my new vector field
so my new vector field
so that's our new vector field this is
the vector field
plus y i plus plus x j and now the curl
is zero everywhere which implies
which means that i could put a twig
anywhere here and i'm not going to get
any kind of rotation let's see if that
makes sense if i put a twig in the
center
if i put a twig in the center or some
kind of stick in the center see i would
have some the forces or the fluids
pushing in in this direction but they're
not helping to rotate and pushing out in
that direction well that's not going to
help me either
right so i'm definitely not going to
rotate there and actually you could draw
put a twig anywhere and maybe a twig
might be pushed in a direction for
example if i put a twig here it's going
to be pushed outward
by the flow of the water by the velocity
of the water but it's not going to
rotate so the internet holds that even
though
i kind of have curl in the x direction
or i have curl in the y direction
they're offsetting each other so that in
two dimensions i actually end up having
no rotation or and actually this is
called a an irrotational i think that's
the word vector field where you're not
going to have any rotation here all of
the
if you think of it as force or velocity
of the vector field is going to be
applying translation to objects in that
field
and actually just for fun let's think
about the divergence of that field just
to i don't know just because i have two
minutes
so if i were to think about the
divergence of that field since it's
fairly easy to calculate
let me erase this real fast
it's always fun to just interpret a
vector field to death let's do the
divergence of this one
so the divergence of that vector field
is just the partial of derivative of
this with respect to x so it's
so div
of v
is the same thing as our del
operator dot
our vector field v
and that's the partial derivative of
this with respect to x well the partial
derivative of y with respect to x is
just 0
plus the partial derivative of
x with respect to y right so this is
zero
so the divergence of this field is zero
and even in the other case when this was
a minus it still would have been zero
and does that make sense
well if we take a circle anywhere here
let's take it in the center because the
center is the most interesting let's
take a circle so we do have some
fluid or particles coming in at a
certain velocity from the bottom right
in the top left but just as much as
coming out through the top right and the
bottom left
right whatever's coming in through here
and here is leaving through there and
there so if i had a infinitesimally
small
circle or sphere in this vector field i
would have no net
density increasing or you know nothing
would be entering into that circle or in
any given amount of time the
concentration of that circle wouldn't
change and that's true pretty much
anywhere if i were to draw a circle if i
were to draw a circle here because the
divergence is zero it's telling us that
whatever is coming in in one direction
is coming out in the other directions so
i'm not getting any denser and or any
less dense i have no divergence or
convergence so that's just interesting
well now i've run out of time so we're
done analyzing this vector field see you
in the next video